bonjour et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition d'en quête d'europe
au menu de cette émission retour sur les
grands dossiers qui ont fait l'actualité
européenne
nous irons tout d'abord en allemagne un
pays en cruel manque de main d'oeuvre
qui fait appel aux jeunes diplômés des
pays en crise
nous reviendrons ensuite sur la crise
qui a frappé les agriculteurs français
en guerre avec leurs homologues
espagnols
enfin direction la hongrie quelques mois
après le passage des boues rouges
toxiques à kolontar comment ce village
s'est il reconstruit mais d'abord on
part en italie à la rencontre de cette
génération perdue qui a du mal à entrer
dans la vie active alors flora pourquoi
parle-t-on de génération perdue en
italie en fait on parle de génération
perdue parce qu'il est très difficile
aujourd'hui d'être un jeune en italie ce
sont les premières victimes de la crise
économique qui touche ce pays
aujourd'hui est très difficile de
trouver un emploi stable c'est un
véritable parcours du combattant et les
chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes 60 % des
18-34 ans vivent encore chez leurs
parents et ce chiffre a triplé depuis
les années 80 tout simplement parce
qu'ils n'arrivent pas à trouver un
emploi et donc à avoir des revenus
réguliers pour pouvoir se permettre de
payer un loyer et de quitter donc leurs
parents et qui était effectivement le
cocon familial
donc là on vous suit direction rome où
vous avez été rencontrés d'urbana tessin
et
à 30 ans giovan à un master en
traduction et un doctorat d'anglais et
d'espagnol
malgré ses diplômes elle peine à trouver
un emploi stable comme beaucoup de
jeunes italiens de sa génération
pour gagner sa vie elle cumule les
contrats précaires et elle donne des
cours particuliers
alors on va commencer le cours
d'espagnol en parallèle des cours
particuliers giovanna un contrat de
projet de 20 heures par semaine dans une
école maternelle un contrat à temps
partiel d'octobre à mai cette jeune
italienne à un but dans la vie obtenir
un cdi
un objectif qui lui semble quasi
inaccessible mon rêve ce serait de
trouver un travail stable un type de
contrat qui ne garantissent plus de
sécurité
le rêve absolu ce serait de trouver un
contrat à durée déterminée ça semble
peut-être dérisoire mais ce n'est pas
une chose facile à trouver
les seules personnes que je connais qui
ont un contrat à durée indéterminée soit
ils sont plus âgés que moi
ils ont sept huit ans de plus que moi et
ils ont eu pendant plus de 15 ans un
emploi précaire soit ils ont passé un
concours d'état pour devenir
fonctionnaire
comme deux tiers des jeunes italiens
giovanna vit encore chez ses parents à
rome avec 800 euros par mois en moyenne
difficile de quitter le cocon familial
ça me plairait d'avoir un appartement à
moi d'avoir mon autonomie
ce n'est pas facile de trouver un
logement avec un emploi comme le mien
car un emploi précaire comme le mien ne
me permet pas de payer un loyer mais
cette veine de vent et les parents de
giovanna sont très préoccupés par
l'avenir de leur fille dans l'enceinte
et listo du délai ya fat malgré les
études qu'elle a fait
le master le dr à des études
universitaires qu'il y aurait dû lui
faciliter son entrée sur le marché du
travail
la réponse n'est pas là tempo passe
aujourd'hui giovanna à 30 ans le temps
passe et elle est obligée de se
contenter de contrats de projets qui ne
correspondent absolument pas aux études
qu'elle a fait
la situation de giovanna est loin d'être
exceptionnelle pier luigi cheli l'une
des figures du système éducatif en
italie vient de publier un ouvrage dans
lequel il incite son fils jeunes
diplômés à quitter le pays
son livre a suscité le débat en italie
les jeunes qui sortent de l'université
avec de bons diplômes ne trouvent pas de
travail dans ce pays où les conditions
économiques sont très difficiles il
préfère partir à l'étranger et en
général ils ne reviennent pas autre
problème la culture du piston elle est
tellement ancrée en italie qu'il est
difficile pour un jeune qui sort de
l'université de trouver un travail
uniquement grâce à ses diplômes l'unique
moyen d'obtenir un travail dans ce pays
est soit de connaître quelqu'un soit de
devenir le porteur d'eau d'un politique
c'est tout un système où ce qui compte
ce n'est pas ce que l'on sait faire mais
ce que l'on est prêt à faire pour
obtenir un emploi
et la crise économique a aggravé les
choses l'italie a le triste record
d'europe du taux de chômage des jeunes
depuis la crise 80 % des suppressions
d'emplois recensés dans le pays ont
concerné les 18 29 ans giovanni à la fin
de l'année 2009
il y avait deux millions de jeunes qui
non seulement n'étudier pas mais qui ne
travaillait pas non plus c'est un
chiffre particulièrement important
encore est cette situation a des
répercussions sur le taux de natalité
d'autant qu'en italie le salaire minimum
et les allocations familiales n'existe
pas on en est à 1,4 enfant par femme
c'est un problème très grave
pour li tec dans notre pays le climat
social
on n'encourage pas vraiment à faire des
enfants
flavio et alessia sont tous les deux
précaires ils s'investissent aux
jeunesses communistes pour essayer de
faire bouger les choses et ils ont fait
de la lutte contre la précarité des
jeunes un combat de tous les jours
d'avoir un contrat d'un jour en semaine
à moi mais c'est très très difficile
qu'un jour quand j'aime aujourd'hui un
contrat à temps de manière exclu d'une
société dont ils dénoncent l'
individualisme les jeunes italiens n'ont
d'autre avenir que la précarité ou
l'exil
alors florac comment expliquez-vous la
difficulté de ces jeunes à intégrer le
marché du travail sous l'ère berlusconi
on à flexibiliser le marché du travail
en 1997 il ya une série de réformes qui
avait pour objectif de flexibiliser ce
marché du travail réforme qui a été
accentuée par la loi 30 en 2003 qui a
créé un certain nombre de contrats de
travail qui conduisent finalement à
l'enterrement la mort du cdi
est ce qu'il ya de l'espoir encore pour
ces jeunes là alors c'est vrai qu' il
n'y a pas beaucoup d'espoir quand on
voit le nombre d'italiens de jeunes
italiens qui sont contraints et forcés a
émigré à l'étranger pour avoir un emploi
stable
on se dit que l'avenir n'est pas rose
pour les jeunes italiens aujourd'hui il
ya un certain nombre d'italiens comme
des jeunes espagnols comme des jeunes
portugais qui sont obligés d'aller à
l'étranger au royaume uni en france en
allemagne pour essayer d'obtenir un
emploi stable un cdi merci flora à
l'instar des jeunes italiens des jeunes
grecs et espagnols sont aussi contraints
d'émigrer pour faire face à la crise ou
en allemagne un des pays les plus
durement touchés par le manque de main
d'oeuvre
bérengère d'un glace s'est rendu
outre-rhin
bérengère vous vous êtes rendus en
allemagne et vous pensiez trouvaient
majoritairement des immigrés issus
d'europe de l'est et pourtant ce ne fut
pas le cas oui car l'allemagne a ouvert
ses frontières aux à ces pays qui ont
nouvellement rejoint l'union en mai 2011
les attendait à peu près 150 mille
personnes finalement il y en a que
trente mille qui sont venus en allemagne
or à cela deux raisons d'abord il ya
plusieurs autres pays européens comme
l'angleterre qui avaient ouvert leurs
frontières bien avant donc les premiers
immigrés sont partis vers ces
destinations la et d'autre part
aujourd'hui les taux de croissance en
pologne lettonie en lituanie sont très
importants donc il ya un différentiel de
niveau de vie qui est pas suffisant pour
tous ces gens aient envie de tout
quitter pour partir en allemagne et donc
du coup vers quel pays les allemands se
sont il tournait alors comme l'allemagne
a besoin de main d'oeuvre la regarder
les pays européens qui avaient des taux
de chômage en augmentation alors c'est
le cas de l'espagne et de la grèce donc
c'est logiquement sur une migration
intra-européennes que l'allemagne se
tourne donc vous avez été à la rencontre
de nigauds aller josé à brême on regarde
votre reportage et en sort perdant suite
voilà quelques semaines que me goaler
josé se sont installés à brême une
métropole animé du nord de l'allemagne
pour ces deux jeunes gens c'est un
véritable changement de vie il ya deux
mois encore il vivait à 1700 km de là
près de leur famille et sous le soleil
de leur pays natal
l'espagne étudiant il était venu à
pondre l'allemand lors d'un programme
erasmus
ne trouvant pas travail intéressant chez
eux ils ont choisi d'émigrer en
allemagne d'accord mais je suis venu ici
car je pense que travailler ici c'est
une bonne opportunité pour mon avenir et
travailler dans une autre langue
c'est très important je crois une
immigration intra-européennes que
l'allemagne ont courage il faut dire
qu'avec un taux de croissance qui frôle
les 3 % et un problème de renouvellement
des générations
le pays à d'importants besoins en main
d'oeuvre lagence pour le travail espère
donc faire venir des diplômés au chômage
dans leur pays avec un taux d'inactivité
des jeunes qui ne cesse de croître
l'espagne et la grèce sont
particulièrement visés on cherche des
gens dans les professions on n'a pas
assez de demandes adressées en allemagne
et celle là la médecine dans les
hôpitaux qu'on cherche des personnes ou
les ingénieurs dans les entreprises ben
c'est très facile de venir saison de la
qualification spécialisés et s'il part
moment
c'est dans cette entreprise de sous
traitance automobile installée à brême
que meego aller josé ont été embauché il
ya quelques semaines
originaire de séville migaud elle a 26
ans à la fin de ses études d'ingénieur
il a cherché du travail pendant six mois
enfin on glass à travers
à ce moment là j'ai répondu à une offre
d'emploi
diabate lors d'une course pour le
travail en espagne
nous avons eu un entretien madrid et
nous avons fait connaissance
cela m'a plu et c'est pour ça que je
travaille ici chez abattent faute de
personnel qualifié
de nombreuses entreprises allemandes
sont aujourd'hui obligés de mettre on
attend des projets c'est cada bat
l'entreprise a connu un important
développement ces dernières années
aujourd'hui elle emploie plus de 250
personnes
mais son expansion est freiné par un
manque de main de c'est pourquoi la
direction a lancé cette campagne de
recrutement d ici on fait tout pour que
les nouveaux salariés se sentent bien et
restons damas il ne s'agit pas seulement
d'être dans le travail
mais dans la vie quotidienne par exemple
nous apportons notre aide dans la
recherche d'un appartement pour l'achat
d'une voiture
nous proposons des cours de langue nous
essayons autant que possible d'intégrer
les gens par exemple en faisant quelque
chose ensemble en dehors d'un travail
outre-rhin les problèmes de main
d'oeuvre ne font que commencer
avec un taux de natalité de 1,4 enfant
par femme
le vieillissement de la population est
inéluctable selon l'union européenne la
population en âge de travailler va même
commencé à diminuer dès 2013 pour
l'institut de l'économie les besoin
d'immigration seront énormes dans les
années à venir
malheureusement il ya une baisse
dramatique de la main d'oeuvre en
allemagne il a manqué cinq millions de
personnes des jeunes qui arrivent sur le
marché du travail ne sont pas
suffisamment nombreux pour remplacer les
travailleurs âgés qui partent à la
retraite
nous estimons qu'il faudra de 300 à 500
mille personnes par an pour combler ce
déficit
un pari difficile puisque l'allemagne
est aujourd'hui le pays européen où
vivent le plus d'étrangers
plus de 7 millions et demi sur 82
millions d'habitants
josé michael ne savent pas encore s'ils
feront toute leur vie en allemagne
pour l'instant il compte rentrer en
espagne d'ici trois ou quatre ans le
temps il espère de laisser passer la
crise
bérengère sait-on combien de jeunes
espagnols sont concernés alors c'est
difficile aujourd'hui d'avoir des
chiffres précis parce qu'il ya pas
besoin de permis pour aller travailler
d'espagne en allemagne par contre on a
quand même quelques indices notamment la
branche espagnole de l' agence adecco
donc il ya eu 110 mille personnes qui
ont immigré en allemagne avec un contrat
de travail à la clé et les demandes pour
travailler à l'étranger elles ont été
multipliées par deux mais ce qui est un
petit peu nouveau dans cette immigration
espagnol sait que longtemps ça a été une
immigration non qualifiés aujourd'hui
c'est quand même des gens très fortement
diplômés
on a par exemple la fédération des
architectes espagnols qui indique
aujourd'hui 73 % de ces jeunes
architectes compte exercer à l'étranger
et est ce que les espagnols sont les
seuls concernés
oriane deuxième pays qui est fortement
concernée c'est la grèce alors le seul
problème par rapport à la grèce c'est la
langue
il ya assez peu de jeunes grecs qui
parle allemand donc qu'ils sont obligés
d'apprendre avant de venir en allemagne
et les demandes au goethe institut ont
progressé de 100 %
merci bérengère autre crise qui secoue
l'europe la crise agricole août 2011 les
agriculteurs français accusent leur
homologues espagnols de concurrence
déloyale au creux de l'été la sphère
prend comme toujours une tournure
politique et c'est sandra cerqueira qui
nous en parle
donc sandra cette crise agricole n'est
pas nouvelle mais cet été elle a pris
une dimension particulière oui cette
année la perte de revenus des
agriculteurs français a été telle que
certains ont dû mettre la clé sous la
porte alors tout l'été ils ont essayé
d'alerter le gouvernement et l'opinion
publique en menant des actions coup de
poing
on se souvient qu'à perpignan ils ont
déversé des kilos de fruits et légumes
devant le consulat espagnol est à la
frontière ils ont carrément arrêter les
camions espagnols et puis détruit les
cargaisons
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai eu envie
d'aller voir dans quelles conditions ces
fruits et légumes était produit ses
fruits et légumes que finalement on
retrouve dans tous les supermarchés
français et européens eh ben on se rend
avec vous à almeria et on s'empare
ensuite des agriculteurs de toute la
france venus dénoncer la concurrence
européenne dont ils se disent victimes
depuis des mois ou est ce la est
exploitant dans le vaucluse manifeste
pour la première fois c'est la mort de
l'agriculture
c'est aujourd'hui qu'il faut la défense
dans son exploitation on cultive la
tomate depuis trois générations
quand ils arrivent en 2002 le chiffre
d'affaires est déjà en baisse pour nous
produire un kilo de tomates grappes ça
nous coûte un euro 17 par kilo produit
est actuellement on est 20 78 centimes
le kilo le prix n'a fait que de l'ulco
dégringolé ces derniers mois
contrairement aux céréales la culture de
la tomate n'est pas mécanisables une
grande partie du travail se fait donc à
la main que toutes les feuilles qui ont
poussé depuis la plantation où la
pauvreté 15 cm âme à cette hauteur là où
là on a à peu près 10 mètres de longueur
de plantes
ça demande un entretien au niveau de
donc les feuillages la taille de
bouquets le ramassage une main-d'oeuvre
payer plus cher en france environ 10
euros de l'heure contre 5 euros 50 en
espagne soit presque deux fois plus
conséquence le coût de production double
lui aussi difficile dans ces conditions
d'être compétitif pour ne plus continuer
à vendre à perte ses agriculteurs
envisagent de ne plus produire de
tomates
si rien ne change
à mille kilomètres de là la région
d'alméria dans le sud de l'espagne
un ancien désert surnommée la californie
de l'europe
quarante mille hectares sous plastique
ici le soleil brille toute l'année sous
ses serres mûrissent même en hiver les
fruits et légumes qui remplissent les
supermarchés européens
la grande majorité des serres appartient
à des petits agriculteurs
francis coup rodrigues est l'un d'eux
toute l'année ils embouchent de nombreux
salariés en majorité des étrangers
quand je fais mes comptes à la fin de la
saison je me rends bien compte que c'est
dans la main d'oeuvre que je dépense le
moins ses plus gros frais vont dans
l'achat du plastique destinés à
entretenir ses serres il admet que sans
cette main d'oeuvre bon marché on ne
produirait pas autant dans la région
dont les premiers immigrés sont arrivés
il y a quelques années on leur a donné
du travail en leur faisais des papiers
maintenant il y en a trop qui veulent
travailler beaucoup trop il en arrive
tous les jours c'est au politique de
résoudre ce problème pas aux
agriculteurs
le soleil se lève sur et les rideaux
capital de l'agriculture intensive entre
6 et 8 heures chaque matin les immigrés
attendent par groupe au bord de la route
qu'une voiture s'arrête pour leur
proposer une embauche même pour une
seule journée va être la crise
les espagnols aussi charge du travail
alors nous on travaille moins parmi ses
ouvriers agricoles 80% d'entre eux sont
des marocains rejoints par des bulgares
et des roumains entrés récemment dans
lieux
susanna est arrivé de bulgarie avec son
fils il y a trois ans et citoyens qui
pour lequel nous blesser je suis là
parce que dans mon pays on gagne très
peu c'est vrai que c'est un travail
difficile
on souffre de la chaleur payer 5 euros
50 de l'heure elle se dit plutôt bien
lotis par rapport à certains
ce syndicaliste lui donnent raison selon
lui seuls 1% des agriculteurs payent
plus de 5 euros
le coup légal les autres employeurs sont
souvent en dessous certains vont jusqu'à
proposer 2 euros 50
quand les travailleurs immigrés commencé
à parler de leurs droits ils se font
très souvent renvoyés nous en recevons
chaque jour ici aux syndicats ce sont
des gens qui ont de l'ancienneté nous ça
travaille pour le même patron depuis
huit ans il cumule les contrats sans
être augmentée mais impossible dit il de
travailler ailleurs
il ya du racisme quand on cherche à
faire autre chose c'est toujours non
parce que le travail difficile c'est
pour les étrangers des bas salaires qui
pourrait encore diminuer
comment ça va les ventes en ce moment
les parents ont négocié emilio pérez
redoutent de voir arriver plus
d'importations marocaine ce serait une
menace directe pour sa coopérative car
au maroc on paye un euro de l'heure on
pourra acheter des produits encore moins
cher mais on ne sera plus compétitif à
nous les espagnols en europe en général
on souffrira beaucoup d'une concurrence
à l'autre aujourd'hui la france demain
l'espagne
d'autant que l'accord entre l'ue et le
maroc pour alléger les droits de douane
pour et aboutir plus rapidement que
l'harmonisation européenne des régimes
sociaux réclamée par les agriculteurs
cendres on le voit très bien dans votre
sujet la clé de cette compétitivité
c'est le tarif de la main d'oeuvre est
ce que vous avez eu du mal aller à la
rencontre de ces de ces immigrés qui
travaillent en espagne oui j'ai du mal à
obtenir l'autorisation de filmer à
l'intérieur des serres parce que les
patrons en fait sont très frileux à
l'idée d'être interviewés car ils se
sentent stigmatisés faut le dire et
montrer du doigt en permanence c'est
aussi un sujet tabou pour les habitants
des les rideaux ils ont du mal à en
parler aussi de cette immigration
on le voit le voit sur ces images les
travailleurs immigrés vivent hors du
centre ville loin des regards dans des
petites baraques de fortune en fait
surnommer la balle et chabot l'asse
comme des bidons
ville voilà exactement c'est en fait des
maisons qui se construisent avec les
morceaux de plastique qui récupèrent
près des serres et donc des conditions
de vie assez extrême pour la plupart
sans eau ni fin ils vivent sans eau ni
électricité
donc c'est vrai que l'intégration de ces
travailleurs est loin d'être facile
est ce qu'il n'ya que la main d'oeuvre
pour expliquer cette concurrence accrue
entre les agriculteurs français et leurs
homologues espagnols nom s'ajoute une
législation en matière de pesticides
beaucoup plus sévères en france ce que
les produits autorisés sont chères en
france et donc les on a de plus en plus
d'agriculteurs qui vont s'approvisionner
en espagne où les produits sont moins
chers et donc pour réduire en fait leur
leurs coûts de production donc on se
retrouve enfin l'effet pervers c'est que
pour ceux qui respectent la loi
il ya là une vraie distorsion de
concurrence est là on a les producteurs
français qui se concurrencent entre eux
merci sandra octobre 2010 une digue de
lusine maziar aluminium cède des boues
rouges toxiques qui n'ont de la ville de
kolontar hongrie
quelques mois après où en est la
reconstruction fabrice künast s'est
rendu sur place
alors fabrice un an après la catastrophe
de kolontar comment avez vous trouvé la
ville et ses habitants
ce qui frappe tout de suite évidemment
c'est l'omniprésence de cette
catastrophe dans les esprits très
rapidement très facilement les gens en
parlent
je pense qu'ils sont encore très
clairement sous le choc la plupart des
maisons pourtant on était rasée et
reconstruite etc il reste encore
quelques vestiges mais c'est vrai que
c'est surtout je pense psychologiquement
que cette catastrophe est encore très
présent qu'ils essayent de revivre mais
elle est encore dans tous les esprits
on
c'était le 4 octobre 2010 une digue cède
l'usiné d'aluminium libère une vague de
boue rouge toxique sur le secteur de
kolontar 11 morts et des dizaines de
maisons détruites
les habitants de ce petit village au sud
de budapest sont encore marqués par la
catastrophe
ça c'est impossible raconter ce que l'on
a vécu et ressenti ce jour-là jolt
étaient présents au moment de la vague
il a aidé les secouristes à chercher les
corps des victimes il a vu le défilé des
officiels dans les jours qui ont suivi
comme beaucoup ici pas question de
critiquer le gouvernement qui a dépensé
plus de 100 millions d'euros pour la
reconstruction
dès le premier jour le premier ministre
les secrétaires d'état et les ministres
ont été très présents pour nous apporter
toute l'aide dont on avait besoin
et encore aujourd'hui ils sont à nos
côtés
autour du village il a fallu changer la
terre contaminée sur plus de 20 cm de
profondeur nettoyé pendant des mois
en apparence plus de trace de la vague
rouge mais qu'en est il des conséquences
sur l'environnement aujourd'hui les
autorités multiplient les contrôles
sanitaires pour rassurer la population
lisez la tient l'un des deux cafés du
village
si elle ne craint pas pour sa santé il
reste des doutes ils ont planté du maïs
ils ont dit que ce n'était pas dangereux
bon bien sûr je n'en mangerai pas cette
année et je n'en donnerai pas aux
animaux mais ils nous ont dit que l'on
pouvait de nouveau vivre ici alors qui
est responsable à budapest la question
dérange
le gouvernement refuse pour l'instant
d'accuser magyar aluminium
l'entreprise mise en cause à kolontar on
peut seulement dire qu'un procès en
cours et que l'on n'a pas d'avis là
dessus je me bagarre aluminium vient
pourtant d'être condamné à une amende
record de près de 500 millions d'euros
mais un appel est en cours ce qui
embarrasse les autorités hongroises ça
qu'elles sont accusés de ne pas
respecter les directives européennes sur
les déchets toxiques
mais oui doit on a complètement repensé
la loi contre ce genre d'accident depuis
notre organisme a par exemple vu ses
pouvoirs augmenter
maintenant on peut superviser toutes les
autres autorités et institutions de
contrôle ou encore faut-il faire
appliquer ses textes pour l'organisation
greenpeace plusieurs sites un qui est
aujourd'hui l'état seraient trop
laxistes
la raison une trop grande proximité
entre le pouvoir et des grands groupes
industriels comme magyar aluminium ou
l'entreprise tata qui exploite un site à
risque au nord du pays depuis quelques
années tata finance les médias proches
du gouvernement ou encore l' académie de
foot
lancé par le premier ministre ils sont
proches à la limite ça pourrait ne pas
être graves
tant qu'il n'ya pas de catastrophe
lo ng multiplient les tests sur le
terrain en particulier à kolontar et le
risque sanitaire serait toujours élevé
la barre selon un rapport du parti vert
européen les autorisations
d'exploitation sont en général donner
trop facilement par les autorités
hongroises
le gouvernement est trop faible pour
faire respecter les lois et les
contrôles sont trop rares mais peut-être
qu'il ne le souhaite pas car l' usine
d'aluminium a changé sa méthode de
stockage et très vite repris son
activité
plus de 6000 emplois de la région
étaient en jeu alors à la mairie de
kolontar
on connaît les chiffres avancés par les
ong mais on s'en tient à la version
officielle les mesures et résultats
officiels montrent que nos terres ne
sont pas contaminés ni dangereuses pour
la santé
c'est tout ce que je peux dire sur les
hauteurs du village
les nouvelles maisons construites pour
les sinistrés des travaux sont presque
finis yano chamakh 10 ont pu emménager
cet été une page se tourne mais la
catastrophe est encore très présente
ce tableau est accroché à cette hauteur
et là vous êtes arrivé jusque là rien de
chez mc 10 ont perdu des proches leurs
maisons et leurs terres dans cette
catastrophe
ils espèrent aujourd'hui pouvoir
retrouver un peu de leur vie d'avant
donc fabrice on le voit clairement dans
votre reportage il existe des liens très
forts entre les milieux industriels et
politiques en fait dans le reportage on
évoque deux groupes
tata et magyar aluminium et ces deux
groupes sont très proches non seulement
des grandes formations politiques
mais aujourd'hui aussi du gouvernement
et c'est toute la difficulté pour le
gouvernement actuel en droit c'est
d'imposer d'être plus exigeant avec ces
groupes qui eux mêmes financent leur
campagne finance des programmes etc
et donc c'est très très compliqué et ça
inquiète les associations s'est inquièté
habitants qui connaissent cette
proximité entre entre les groupes et
les autorités parce qu'elle a en fait la
problématique c'est que la hongrie n'a
jamais transposer la directive qui
encadre en fait ces industries à risque
alors il ya un an au moment de la
catastrophe
l'europe a tapé du poing sur la table en
disant vous ne respectez pas les normes
européennes
parce que ces boues rouges ne devait pas
être toxiques elles peuvent être
entreposés mais ne doivent plus être
toxiques depuis la hongrie a fait amende
honorable
elle annonce que les normes sont
respectées qu'elle s'est mis en règle
vis-à-vis de ces normes européennes mais
beaucoup en doutent et en particulier
des associations environnementales
évidemment et au long de votre enquête
vous avez fini par découvrir qu'il
existe un lieu similaire en france il
est à gardanne pas très très loin de
cassis ce qui pose problème c'est que il
rejette en mer une bonne partie de leur
production de déchets de l'ordre de 300
mille tonnes quand il faut imaginer 300
mille tonnes de déchets qui le rejette à
10 km au large en méditerranée au large
de cassis donc pas très loin des
calanques pas très loin de parcs
naturels et évidemment les associations
ici comme greenpeace ou autres sont très
inquiet parce que serge est interdite en
grèce ou au japon sont encore autorisées
et ce jusqu'en 2015 parce que la france
est octroyé une dérogation pour
autoriser ces ce rejet de déchets en
méditerranée évidemment ça pose des
vraies questions environnementales dans
le dans le secteur de cassis merci
beaucoup fabrice c'est fini pour cette
fois nous on se retrouve très vite sur
public sénat et tous les jours sur
publicsenat.fr